Nikki Bella and boyfriend artemchik
Vincent pack on the PDA as several of
our favorite stars serve up serious
summer swag at the 2019 Teen Choice
Awards we spend a lot of time together
and they need a lot from us we do need a
lot and Nikki and Artem definitely gave
it to us
check out the couple on the blue carpet
they kissed snap selfies and even showed
off a sexy dance move I love everything
about this guy he's awesome and amazing
and so sweet Lucy Hale hosted the show
I'm very excited the brunette beauty
looked radiant in a red mini dress the
teens are keeping me young I like learn
about all these new things and people
it'll be a good thing
Taylor Swift brought lots of color to
the carpet fibers a chi
[Music]
newly-engaged Sarah Hyland stepped out
with her blingy new accessory do you
think about what the engagement ring
could look like one day do you have
ideas I'm a 27 year old woman of course
hahaha he knows what it is so it's fine
and we can't help but notice the almost
bride looks good in white I'm really
excited for future more bright looks
from zendaya Maddie Ziegler and Laura
Marano but we saw some darker hues too
Lauren Gerrie guai switched up her look
swapping light for dark in a
form-fitting dress Jessica Alba and
Brittany Snow also went bold in black
while Chloe and Halle wore earth tones
with subtle but sexy cutouts
[Music]